[Music]
foreign
I have the honor to teach the upcoming
Workshop engaging in beautiful data
visualizations with gtbot 2 a deposit
Confluence which is going to happen this
year in September in Chicago
because for anyone who already knows the
fundamental principles of this graphic
library but doesn't want to only create
simple and basic charts but go beyond
that and create custom and detailed
Graphics that stand out and successfully
tell a story by guiding and engaging the
viewer so here three main reasons why I
think we don't want to miss this
Workshop
first is that you will get insights and
hands-on experience on how to design
Advanced Data visualizations with code
only I will share helpful tricks
exciting essential packages and other
useful utilities that I've guided over
the years working with this powerful
Library
a range of examples of popular and less
common chart types will showcase the
potential of digital 2 to create any
graphic you can think of or reproducible
transparent and without the need for any
manual post-processing
second you will learn how to Leverage
The Power of digital 2 to ensure a
corporate and custom look and be more
efficient
I'll cover how to modify any aspect of
your graphic and also how to create your
own corporate themes and color scales
with sensible defaults and personal
options if you want
this will hopefully help you your team
and potential collaborators to design
graphics with a consistent look in a
more efficient way while providing all
the flexibility that digital has to
offer
and last but not least you also learn
how to create charts that provide a
clear narrative and guide the viewers I
will show you how to use suitable colors
modify labels add annotations and other
highlights to enrich your visualizations
empowering you to apply the general
basic principles of graphical
storytelling when working with digital
2. so these are some of the highlights
of the upcoming workshop on digital 2
and if this sounds interesting then
don't miss this opportunity and join us
at the positive conference in Chicago
[Music]